Let's start here--palace minus walk.
This is a lot like 5 minus 3 if "palace" and "walk" are identifiers.
Here the parentheses are balanced. We like this utterance.
Here we start a bold tag and right "naguib," but we never close off the bold tag.
This is not balanced.
Here we start an italics tag and write "mahfouz," and then we close off the italics tag.
This is well-balanced.
Here we write open "pulitzer" plus open "prize" close close--
open parenthesis, open parenthesis, close, close.
This one matches there. This one matches there. These are well-balanced.
You might think there's no reason to put "prize" in parentheses,
and you might not if you were writing, but the grammar--the language--
allows it as long as the parentheses are balanced.
Over here this one is particularly tricky.
We have a close parenthesis followed by "1956" followed by an open parenthesis.
Now, the number of open and close parentheses is the same,
so you might think it's balanced, but they're in the wrong order.
We need to do the opening before the closing. This does not match.
"Naguib Mahfouz" is a relatively famous Egyptian writer.
He wrote Palace Walk. It's set in about 1917 around the end of World War I in Egypt in Cairo.
It details what goes on with Al-Sayyid Ahmad Abd al-Jawad and his family.
My best attempt at doodling Egypt or Cairo is someone next to a pyramid.
You can tell it's a pyramid because it's clearly labeled.